hey everyone welcome to the typescript
tutorial in this tutorial we will cover
everything you need to know about
typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is superset of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported
let's look at today's agenda
we'll first understand what is
typescript
followed by which we'll look at the
typescript tutorial
then we will see the difference between
javascript versus typescript
followed by which we will understand
some of the concepts in typescript
generics
then we will see how to interface
typescript with react with nodejs and
with express tutorial then we will look
at some of the advanced typescript
concepts followed by which we will
create a real-time chat application
project using typescript javascript and
node.js
and at last we will look at typescript
interview questions which will help you
crack any typescript interview at ease
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click on the bell icon so you never miss
an update from simply learn so without
any further ado let's get started
what is typescript
typescript is object oriented and
strongly type programming language which
is superset of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in a
browser or node.js and any other
application hypscript was designed by
anders hegelsberg at microsoft the
limitations of javascript for the
development of large scale application
at the microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
the complicated javascript code there
was demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript is javascript with some
additional features
to support a strong interaction with
your editor typescript adds additional
syntax to javascript typescript is a
scripting language that understands
javascript and uses type inference to
provide powerful capabilities without
the need for additional code
why typescript compilation javascript is
an interpreted language there is no need
to compile it as a result it must be run
to ensure that it is genuine if there is
an error that implies you write all the
code to find out an output
as a result you will have to spend hours
looking for the faults in the code so
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation errors this aids in the
detection of mistakes prior to the
execution of the script
typescript provides an optional type
system for javascript code when a client
doesn't have a value for a parameter he
can pass a null optional arguments are
features of typescript we can declare
some arguments in the function optional
by utilizing optional parameter features
so that the client is not necessary to
supply a value to optional parameters
strong static typing javascript does not
have a powerful static typing system
does the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls that is a
typescript language service can deduce
the type of variable defined with
nodetype based on its value
supports object-oriented programming
such as classes interfaces inheritance
and other object-oriented programming
principles are supported by typescript
typescript supports type definitions
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions
external javascript libraries are
defined in typescript definition files
as a result these libraries can be
included in typescript code
now let us look at the difference
between typescript versus javascript
typescript is an object-oriented
programming language
whereas javascript is a scripting
language
and typescript supports static typing
whereas javascript does not support
static typing
errors can be found and corrected during
compile time in javascript errors can be
found only during the runtime as it is
an interpreted language
there is a concept for es3 es4 es5 and
es6 in typescript whereas no support for
compiling additional es3 es4 es5 or as6
features in javascript
functions can have optional parameters
in typescript whereas this feature is
not possible in javascript
converted into javascript code to be
understandable for browsers in
typescript
in javascript this can directly be used
in browsers
in typescript proper build setup is
required for static type definitions
no build setup is required in javascript
now let us look at the features of
typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly super set of
javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodes comprehend
javascript typescript compiles to
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript typescript
unlike its computators does not require
dedicated virtual machine or a specific
runtime environment to run typescript is
superset of javascript
it's a strong syntactical superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing
typescript is a large-scale application
development language that transcompiles
to javascript
typescript is static and typescript is
object oriented language
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter
he can personal optional arguments are a
feature of typescript
when it comes to object-oriented
programming with javascript javascript
shines because of the class keyword it
makes object-oriented programming look
quite similar to programming in other
object-oriented languages like c-sharp
or java
applications of typescript
typescript can be used to develop
javascript applications for both
client-side and server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code
typescript is used for building
large-scale application for enterprises
advantages of typescript
highlights error at the compilation time
during the time of development
in typescript it runs on any browser or
javascript engine
typescript has a namespace concept by
defining a module
typescript support strongly typed or
static typing
disadvantages of typescript typescript
takes a long time to compile the code
typescript does not support abstract
classes
typescript has extra compilation step
for converting typescript into
javascript typescript has an overly
complicated typing system
setting up development environment
firstly we need to go to node.js
official website and install node.js
after installing
go to command prompt and type the
function
node space hyphen v to check if the node
is installed properly
to install typescript
run the command
in pm note package manager install
globally type script in the command
prompt and this will install typescript
so let's jump to the browser and see the
installation of load.js and typescript
then we will go to visual studio and see
the different components like loops
variables data types with examples
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more so to install
node.js come to the website nodejs.org
here come to the downloads and from here
you can install node.js
node is an open source server side
execution platform for javascript code
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat
news feeds and web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from browser to the server
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
v8 javascript engine from chrome
node.js is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
to install for windows click on windows
if you have mac os
click on mac os to install
so i'll click on windows here we go
node.js is getting installed
since i have already installed in my
device i'll cancel it
so once the installation is complete and
you have installed the node.js
next go to command prompt
in the command prompt run the command
node
hyphen v to check if whether the nodejs
is installed properly
and here it shows the version of nodejs
installed in our device
so here we can see that node is
installed
properly next we need to install
typescript
to install typescript we need to run the
command npm node package manager
install
hyphen g globally type script
if you run this command the typescript
will be installed
the typescript will be installed
worldwide with this command
this implies that each project you
create on your computer can use
typescript dependencies without having
to reinstall the typescript package
so after running this the typescript
will be installed since i have already
installed will clear this
so after installing typescript to check
if whether the typescript is installed
properly
to check if the compiler is installed
just type dsc typescript compiler space
hyphen version
and here you can see the typescript
compiler of version 4.5.4 is installed
now that we know how to install node.js
and
type script now we will go to visual
studio and
see the
examples
so let us see the different types of
variables available in typescript for
variable declaration typescript follows
the same rules as javascript variables
can be declared with the commands like
variable
or we have
let
and we have constant
const
so these are the three types of variable
declarations available in typescript
we'll see them one by one
variables can be declared in typescript
using the var keyword just like in
javascript
the scoping rules are identical to those
in javascript
for example we can declare a variable
of parameter h
and it is of the type number
which is equal to
say 45 something like this
and similarly we have
let
so let is a ecmascript 6 introduced two
new types of variable declarations in
javascript using the keyword let and
const to solve the issues with variable
declarations
these additional sorts of variable
declarations are also supported by
typescript which is a superset of
javascript
for example we have let say employee
name
is equal to john
similarly we have constant
constant variables are declared in the
same way as variable and let variables
are constant transforms are variable
into a constant whose value cannot be
changed the same scoping constraints
apply to constant variable as they do to
the led variables
for example we have constant
num
is equal to
100
something like this
next we will look at the different data
types in typescript
we have different data types like number
string
boolean array
etc
so number first we'll look at the number
just like javascript typescript supports
number data type
all numbers are stored as floating point
numbers
these numbers can be a decimal
hexadecimal
for example
say let
first
number
one two
three so
let's again
the third number
is equal to this is of the type now we
will write octal
and don't forget to put colon otherwise
it will show an error
select fourth
now we'll declare the number of
say binary
so typescript supports number data types
like the numbers can be stored in
floating point numbers
or decimal or hexadecimal octal or
binary
so this is basically a number
and this is
hexadecimal
[Music]
this is octal
and
this is binary these are the different
number methods in typescript
the method two exponential returns the
exponential notation in string format
two fixed returns the fixed point
notation in string format
to locate string converts a number into
a local specific representation of the
number
two precision returns a string
representation in exponential or fixed
point to be specified precision
tostring returns a string representation
of the number in the specified base
and value of returns a primitive value
of the number next we have string then
the data type which we have is string
string is an another primitive data type
that is used to store text data
string values are surrounded by single
quotation marks or double quotation mark
for example
we say declare it let employee
name
string of the type string
is equal to
johnson
so this is of the type
string the different string methods in
typescript are
method character at returns the
character at the given index concatenate
returns a combination of two or more
specified strings
index off returns an index of first
occurrence of this specified substring
from a string and -1 if not found
the method replace replaces the matched
substring with a new substring
in the method split splits the string
into substrings and returns an array
two upper case converts all the
characters of the string into upper case
two lower case converts all the
characters of the string into the lower
case
the next type which we have is boolean
boolean values are supported by both
javascript and typescript and stored as
true or false
example for boolean is say let
here note that the boolean with small b
is different from the boolean capital b
so the upper case boolean is an object
type whereas the lowercase boolean is a
primitive type
it is always recommended to use the
primitive type boolean that is a
lowercase boolean in the code because
while javascript courses an object to
its primitive type the typescript type
system does not the typescript treats it
like in the object type
the another data type is of the type
array
an array is a special type of data type
which can store multiple values of
different data types sequentially using
a special syntax
typescript supports array similar to
javascript there are two ways to declare
an array one is using the square
brackets and the other is using a
generic array type
example
this is one type to declare with the
square brackets
and the other type is to use
the generic array type
both methods produce the same output
arrays can contain elements of any data
types numbers strings or even objects
arrays can be declared and initialized
separately
these are the different array methods in
typescript
we have pop that removes the last
element of the array and returns that
element and push adds the new elements
to the array and returns the new array
length
sort sorts all the elements of the array
and similarly we have concat index of
copy within
fill shift splice
and shift
includes join
last index of
that returns the last index of the
element in an array similarly we have
slice to string
and to locate string similarly we have
tuple
union any word and never as the data
types in typescript
next we will look at the if statement in
typescript
an if statement can include one or more
expressions which return boolean if the
boolean expression evaluates to true
a set of statements is then executed and
in if else condition an if else
condition includes two blocks
if block and an else block if the if
condition evaluates to true then if
block is executed otherwise the else
block is executed
and we also have elsif
so the elsif statement can be used for
if statement
next we will see loops in typescript
typescript supports for loop the for
loop is used to execute a block of code
a given number of times which is
specified by a condition
so this is the for loop
the first expression is executed before
the for loop starts and the second
expression is the condition for the loop
to execute and the third expression is
executed after the execution of every
code block here in this example i is
equal to 0 declares and initializes a
variable the second condition i is less
than 3 checks whether the value of i is
less than 3 or not if it is less then it
exits the loop
the third statement
increases the value of i by 1
this loop will execute the block 3 times
until the value of i becomes 3. now that
we have seen loops we'll see the
functions in typescript
functions are the primary blocks of any
program functions are the most important
part
since it is a functional programming
language with functions we can implement
the concepts of oops like classes
objects polymorphism and abstraction
functions ensure that the program is
maintainable and revisible and organized
into readable blocks while typescript
provides a concept of classes and module
functions still are integral part of the
language for example
we have function
sum
so this is the example of function
classes in typescript now let us look at
the classes in typescript
so in object oriented programming
classes are fundamental entities used to
create reusable components
typescript has been primarily a
functional programming language
where inheritance is prototype based
functions are used to build reusable
components
let us see an example for the classes
employee name
so we'll create a class employee
and
provide employee
id
employee name
so the typescript compiler
will convert the class to the javascript
code using the closure
and the constructor
is a special type of method which is
called when creating an object in
typescript the construction method is
always defined with the name constructor
so in this example the employee class
includes a constructor with the
parameter employee id
in the constructor members of the class
can be accessed using this keyword
example this dot employee id
it is not necessary for every class to
have a constructor
first up what is javascript
now javascript is a powerful client-side
scripting language
it is mainly used for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
in other words you can make your web
page more lively and interactive with
the help of this language
javascript is also being used widely in
game development web development server
development and robotics among others so
talking about why javascript is being
used
first up is that it's open source
next as discussed earlier it has
excellent user interaction
meaning the scripts are basically
written in html pages and are executed
automatically with embedded javascript
also javascript offers a wide range of
libraries and frameworks some popular
ones are react
angular vue.js among others
and some other key features of
javascript include excellent speed
cross browser compatibility that is
javascript code runs on all browsers
like google chrome
firefox safari you name it
and lastly simple things are done simply
it offers simple semantics allowing a
seamless developer experience
then what exactly is typescript
now typescript is an object oriented
programming language which is a superset
of javascript
it's basically javascript with other
impressive additional features
and all the code written in typescript
gets compiled to javascript ultimately
now let's look at some of the key
features of typescript that make you
want to use it
firstly it's a superset of javascript as
mentioned earlier typescript is a
superset of javascript
now it supports all javascript libraries
and apis
in fact angular which is a javascript
framework
that is used to build single page
applications is completely written in
typescript
now typescript uses object-oriented
programming concepts
with the increase in code complexity
javascript had to fulfill the
requirements of object-oriented
programming
hence typescript was introduced to
bridge the gap
typescript helps with quicker code
development thus improving performance
and lastly as mentioned earlier it adds
several additional features to
javascript making coding excessively
easy
now let's look at some of the advantages
of typescript over javascript
typescript always points out the
compilation errors at the time of
development
now because of this at the run time the
chances of getting errors are very less
however in case of javascript it's an
interpreted language and all errors are
shown during runtime
next typescript supports static typing
this means that all the variables that
are used in your program are basically
known during compile time
now since this feature is
used it leads to better code completion
type checking tooling and refactoring
as mentioned earlier typescript adds a
lot of features to javascript right so
typescript adds features like interfaces
generics namespaces null checking and
access modifiers
and lastly it provides excellent tooling
with intellisense which provides active
hints as the code is typed
moving ahead
i am sure you must have gathered the
differences between the two languages
however let me just brief them up for
you
firstly typescript is object oriented
language while javascript is a
client-side scripting language
now typescript supports
strongly typed and static typing feature
while javascript does not support it
in case of typescript errors are
highlighted at the time of development
making it easier for codes to run
however
javascript makes sure that it highlights
errors at run time
now typescript code is always converted
to javascript and then run on browsers
while javascript directly runs on
browsers
now typescript supports prototyping
while javascript does not support
prototyping
lastly as mentioned typescript supports
modules generics
namespaces access modifiers etc
while javascript does not support these
features
so lastly which one should you choose
now what are the developers around the
world using
according to google trends
growth in typescript has plateaued in
the last 12 months while javascript
still has a large user base
so with that you can gather that a lot
of developers out there prefer
javascript over typescript
but if you wonder which one suits you
better
well if you are an experienced developer
and work on smaller projects then
javascript is ideal
but if you prefer a statically typed
language
and you are working on a new library or
a framework or if you're working in a
big project with multiple developers
then typescript would be a better option
what is typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
type safety is provided via generics
without sacrificing performance or
efficiency
the type variable in typescript is used
to denote types and uses generics
generic functions have the same type as
non-generic functions with type
arguments specified first as in function
declarations
why use typescript generics
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with the specific type
or identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument as a result
when function returns we lose
information about what the type was the
only information we have is that any
type could be produced if we pass in a
string
we need the means to capture the
argument type in such a way that we can
use it to signify what is been returned
as well we will utilize a type variable
here which is a form of variable that
deals with types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called time this type allows us
to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example a number or a string so that
we can use it later we are going to
utilize the type as a return type once
more
we can use two methods to invoke generic
identity function after writing it one
method is to pass all the parameters to
the function including the type argument
the other method is to utilize type
argument inference
now let us look at the typescript
generic types
generic functions have the same type
parameters as non-generic functions with
the type parameters listed first as in
the function declarations
we can call the generic type parameter
in the type by whatever name we like as
long as the number of type variables and
how they have utilized match
the generic type can also be written as
a call signature of an object literal
type
typescript generic classes
a generic class resembles a generic
interface in appearance
following the name of class generic
classes contain a generic type parameter
list enclosed in angular brackets
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type instead we
may have used string or even more
complicated objects
a class type has two sides a static side
and an instant side generic classes are
only generic on the instant side not on
the static side hence static members
can't use the class type parameters
while working with them
although this is relatively literal use
of the generic number class you will
notice that nothing restricts it to
using only the number type
instead we may have used string or even
more complicated objects
putting the type parameter on the class
itself like the interface ensures that
all of the classes property functions
with the same type
typescript generic constraints
typescript generic types allow you to
work with any data type we can however
use constraints to limit it to a
specific types
a type parameter can be declared that is
limited by another type parameter for
instance in this case we would like to
retrieve a property from an object based
on its name we'll put a constraint
between two types to ensure that we are
not obtaining a property that does not
exist on the object
now let us jump into visual studio code
and understand typescript generics more
better so here we are in visual studio
code the prerequisite is we need to
install node.js
and we need to install typescript
so let's get started
let's call a function
function identity
identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter we could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or with any type
so this is the identity function with
specific type so if we had to write the
same
in the identity function with the
specific type so what we'll do
we'll write it with the specific type
so to write it with any type
what we have to do is we'll write any
in place of string
so while the use of n is generic when we
use any the function accepts any kind of
the type of the argument as a result
when the function returns we lose the
information about what that type was the
only information we have is that any
type could have produced if we pass in a
string
so we are passing up the type string
here and maybe we can pass this type as
number as well instead of string
so i can make this function generic by
passing the type any but this will lose
information about what type was passed
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what has been
returned as well so we will utilize a
type variable here which is of the form
variable that deals with the types
rather than the values
so for that we will write the code as
create a function
identity
so here the identity function now has a
type variable called the type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize a type as
a return type once more so we can use
one of the two methods to invoke the
generic identity function after writing
it
so i have written a few lines of code
with generic type function
so here i have written a few lines of
code in this example the type variable t
is specified with the function in the
angle brackets get array
so the type variable t also is used to
specify the type of the arguments and
then return the value
this means that the data type which will
be specified at the time of a function
call will also be the data type of the
arguments and of the return value
so we call generic function get array
and the pass numbers array the strings
array for example calling the function
as get array number and we have passed
the numbers as 16 and decimal number 2.0
and 55.
this will replace t with the number and
so the type of the arguments and the
return value will be the number array in
the same way for get array string we
have passed the values as hello world
the type arguments and the return value
will be a string array so now the
compiler will show an error if you try
to add a string in number array or a
number in string array thus we get the
type checking advantage
so it is not recommended but we can also
call a generic function without
specifying the type variable the
compiler will use the inference to set
the value of t on the function based on
the data type of the argument values
now let us run this code and check
so let us go to the terminal and let us
first run the command
typescript.cmd and the file name type.ts
enter
now let us run the file
nodetype.js
and here we go
it's showing the number array as
1.5 to 36 and 400 we have pushed two new
values one for the number array that is
value 400 and for the string array hello
typescript
what is react
react is a javascript library for
creating user interfaces that is
declarative efficient and customizable
react allows to build complicated user
interfaces out of components which are
small independent pieces of code
react was first open sourced in 2013 by
facebook and has since become one of the
most popular libraries in the front end
world
with frameworks like redux react can
simply be extended to integrate
functionality like routing and state
management patterns
features of react
react is an open source library and is
developed by facebook
react apps are fast flexible modular and
scalable
react is powerful javascript libraries
that creates interactive interfaces
popular libraries of react are redux
material design and chest
redux helps manage state in javascript
redux is the most popular of all react
libraries because it easily tracks the
state as the application size grows
react has robust developer community and
variety of libraries
react is declarative and component based
declarative views make the react code
more predictable and easier to debug
and react is component based that is
react letters build encapsulated
components that manage their own state
and compose them to make complex uis
advantages of using typescript with
react
in a react project typescript allows us
to write html code directly typescript
delivers superior intellisense and code
completion for jsx when used with react
javascript xm is abbreviated as jsx
when using ides like visual studio
visual studio code autumn webstorm
eclipse and others typescript comes in
handy this allows better development by
improving autocomplete and snippet
generation
typescript has code that is easy to read
and understand
typescript is statically typed language
the distinction between statically and
dynamically typed programming languages
is when type checking occurs
variables in static language are type
checked
while creating react app complex type
definitions can be defined as interfaces
in typescript this is useful when you
wish to use a complex type in the
application such as an object with
multiple properties
microsoft supports typescript
an open source programming language
millions of developers all over the
world enjoy and use it this implies that
if you get stuck while learning or using
typescript you can easily obtain help
and answers on the community portal
we can integrate typescript into our
existing react projects for this we can
configure the typescript compiler
installing and configuring typescript
and react
before we install typescript we need to
install node.js
go to the node.js official website and
you can install node.js from there once
you install node.js
go to the command prompt and run this
command npm install hifunji typescript
this command is used to install
typescript
globally once you have installed
typescript to check if the typescript is
installed properly run the command tsc
typescript compiler
hyphen v to check the version of the
typescript compiler
next we need to install react
for installing react and creating a
react project
go to the command prompt and run this
command
npx create react app this command will
create a simple folder structure of the
application then install all the
necessary modules and get the project up
and running for you
first of all we need to install node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website of node
nodejs.org
go to the downloads in downloads here
you can
install the node.js if you have windows
if you have mac os
you can install it from here so i have
windows so i'll install windows since i
have already installed so i'll cancel it
so once you have installed node.js then
go to the command prompt
in command prompt we need to install the
typescript to install the typescript run
the command npm that is node package
manager
install
hyphen g
g stands for installing globally
and then typescript
what this command does is it installs
the typescript globally
run this command once you run this
command the typescript will be installed
since i have already installed
typescript i'll cancel it so after you
have installed typescript to check if
the typescript is installed properly run
the command typescript compiler tsc
space
hyphen hyphen b
and press enter
and this will show the version
and this will show the version of the
typescript installed so i have version
4.5.4 installed in my device
so after this to get started with the
project after successful installation of
node.js and typescript let us create a
new folder to create a new folder type
the command make directory
and
we'll name the folder as
typescript
hyphen
react
so enter
so we have created the new folder next
we'll change the directory to the folder
which we created so cd
to
ts react
so after this we need to initiate the
project
so to initiate the project will run the
command npm
init
it is asking for package name
just
click enter
and
click enter
then is this okay click s
after this what we need to do is create
react app
so to create react app run the command
npx
space create
reactor
and enter
so this command will create a simple
folder structure for your application
and then install all the necessary
modules and get your project up and
running for you
so this is the project folder which i
have already created
i have the vs code folder wherein i have
settings.json files in this then i have
installed all the node modules
then i have the source folder
in source folder i have app.tsx file
counter.esx
index.html declarations index.dx file
to install webpack just run the command
npm install webpack
space webpack hyphen cli in the terminal
this will install the webpack
so i'll show you a simple hello world or
hello everyone program
so in app.esx
we'll just type hello everyone
and we'll give the color as green and
align the text at the center input since
we have imported the counter
file so in counter file
we'll just type it subscribe to simply
learn with text align in the center and
with the color red
so we'll just run this
here we go we have the message hello
everyone and subscribe to simply
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
the version 8 javascript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat
news feeds and web push notifications
because it allows for a persistent
connection from the browser to the
server
the current coding method such as static
typing and type checking are supported
by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop
server-side apps with rigorous type
checking avoiding run type errors and
other typescript benefits while
maximizing node.js capabilities
now let's see how to set up the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads
so here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for windows mac os
and source code
so go to windows if you have windows pc
and click on install
click on windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since i have
already installed in my device i'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my
system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since i have already installed
typescript in my device
we'll cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and node.js
let's see
example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into visual studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
visual studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
we'll write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
we'll call the function sum and we'll
provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5
so let's
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd
type.ts command
then we'll hit that
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see
it's showing the value showing the
output as forty nine plus five the sum
of nine plus five is forty so we'll
delete this
and
write another program
to show a hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
message
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
we'll call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
so here we go showing welcome to simply
learn
what is
express.js express.js is a node.js web
application framework that is free and
open source
it is used to quickly and easily design
and create web apps web applications are
applications that can be run through a
web browser because express.js simply
requires javascript
programmers and developers may create
web applications and apis with little
effort
tj holloway chook created express which
is now maintained by node.js and several
open source contributors
to construct our applications express
provides a simple interface it gives us
the resources we need to create our app
it's adaptable because there are a lot
more modules on npm that can be directly
integrated into express
let us look at some of the features of
express.js
server-side development is made easier
with express it's possible to create
single page multi-page and hybrid web
apps with express.js
express enables middlewares to respond
to http request to be configured
middleware is primarily responsible for
the orderly structure of express js
various functions
express js has a comprehensive routing
mechanism that uses urls to maintain the
state of a web page
it establishes a routing table that is
used to carry out various operations
based on the http method and url
express.js has templating engines that
enable developers to create dynamic
content for web pages by creating html
templates on the server
express js simplifies debugging by
offering a debugging mechanism that can
pinpoint a particular area of the web
application that is causing problems
advantages of express.js
express.js makes developing node.js web
applications quickly and easily
express.js is simple to set up and
personalize
it allows to define application routes
using http methods and urls
express.js includes a number of
middleware modules that can be used to
execute additional request and responses
activities
it is simple to interface with a variety
of template engines including
jade vash and ejs
it allows us to specify middleware for
handling errors
express is used to make a rest api
server and it's simple to provide your
application static files and resources
databases such as mongodb redis and
mysql are simple to connect to
express.js
now let us look at the demo on
typescript express
the prerequisites are we need to have an
editor maybe visual studio code then we
need to have node.js installed and a
package manager installed such as npm or
yarn
so we'll jump into visual studio code
here i have created a new folder
named express script then we will go to
the terminal
next we'll run the command
npx
type script
hyphen init will initialize typescript
next to initialize the node.js
application will run the command
yarn
in it
once we have initialized the node.js
application we just need to click enter
just click
enter
and we have successfully saved the
package.json file
next we need to
make a new directory
we'll make a new directory source
next we'll install the touch cli
globally
with the command npm install
touch
cli
so after installing this we'll run the
command
touch
source inside the source folder we will
create the file app.ts
so here you can see we have created the
file app.ts inside the source folder
so after this we will install typescript
to install typescript run the command
yarn
add
type script
node
dev
type script
friendly
so after this we need to install express
to install express run the command
yarn
space add
express
next we need to add node modules and
express modules for that run the command
yarn
add
type slash node
type slash express
so let us now go to the app.ts file
and
run the code
we'll close this
so i'll copy paste a few lines of code
here
wherein i have imported express
module
the constant app creates an express
function
and we have express.json
and we have returning a message hello
world
so we'll save this and we are running it
on the local host with port number 3000
so we'll save this
and
run it
to run it we'll just
run the command e on
def
so application is listening at the
local host 3000 so we'll copy this
and open in the browser
here we got showing the message hello
world
similarly we have routing
like this example with app.get and
app.host the app object provides a
collection of functions that attach
callbacks to http request made to
defined destinations
and other http methods such as post put
patch and delete can also have callbacks
attached to them
the router object is another approach to
setup routing
you can call the get put and patch and
delete methods on a router object just
like you do on a app object
and similarly we have
request and response
so the request object holds information
about http request including headers
query strings and parameters
when when an http request is received
the response object represents the http
response that the application provides
similarly for response the send method
is the most significant one it sends the
http response to the client so that it
can be received
the function accepts a variety of data
kinds including strings objects arrays
and buffers
the send method finishes the response
process with data but you can
alternatively use the end function to
end it without any data
the request and response objects are
accessible to middleware function
it can join the request response cycle
at any point
a third argument that middleware
receives is the next function
the get callback which processes the
http get request that we wrote in this
example
is an example of middleware
it's highly unique middleware that only
works in one situation they can also
carry out more general duties
we'll first look at type assertions
type assertion is similar to type cast
in other languages but it does not do
any additional verification or
restructuring
it has no effect on runtime and is only
used by the compiler typescript expects
that you the programmer have completed
the necessary and specific checks
so there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax
and the other one is the angle bracket
syntax both versions are identical
choosing one over the other is primarily
a matter of preference
however only as style assertions are
allowed when combining typescript with
jsx
type aliases type aliases give a type a
new name
type aliases are similar to interfaces
in that they can be used to name
primitives unions tuples and any other
kind that you would have to define by
hand otherwise
aliasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives the type a new name
aliasing a primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes
type aliases like interfaces can be
general all we have to do is add type
parameters and utilize them on the right
side of the alias declaration
this is the syntax for type aliases
type generics
type generics is a tool for creating
reusable components in typescript
rather than working with a single data
type it builds a component that can
interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their kinds
generics ensure that the software is
both adaptable and scalable over time
consider the below code without generics
the identity function is a function that
returns whatever is sent in as a
parameter you could either provide the
identity function with a specific type
or the identity function with any type
while the use of any is generic when you
use any the function accepts any kind
for the type of argument
as a result when the function returns
you lose the information about what the
type was the only information you have
is that any type could be produced if
you pass a string
so for that we need the means to capture
the argument type in such a way that we
can use it to signify what is being
returned as well
we will utilize a type variable here
which is a form of variable that deals
with the types rather than values
the identity function now has a type
variable called type this type allows
you to capture the type of data the user
supplies
for example
a number or a string so that you can use
it later you are going to utilize type
as the return type once more
next we look at the in operator
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have an optional or required property n
and the false branch narrows to the
types that have an optional or missing
property n
for a n in x expression
where n is a string literal or a string
literal type and x is the union type
below is an example code for inoperator
null and undefined are two special types
in typescript that have the values null
and undefined respectively they are not
particularly useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default that means you
can give things like number null and
undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is set
however null and undefined can also be
assigned to unknown any and the
respective types
this helps you avoid a lot of frequent
errors you can use them as union type
string null and undefined if you want to
send in either a string null or a
undefined
next we have index types
using index types we can get the
compiler to check code that utilizes
dynamic property
names by using index types a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object's property
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and index access operators
let us jump into visual studio code and
understand index types more better
so consider this code as an example for
index types here key of t the index type
query operator
for any type t e of t is the union of
non-public property names of t
and t of k the indexed access operator
is the second operator
the type syntax reflects the expression
syntax in this case
and t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where its truly potential can
be seen
all we have to do now is make sure that
the type variable k extends e of t
in get property o
t and property name k so that means of
property name the compiler will initiate
the actual type of the key after you
return t of k result therefore the
return type of get property will change
depending on which property you request
index signature
index signature interact with the key of
and the t of k
the type of an index igniter argument
must be either a string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature key of t will be a string or a
number
because in javascript you can access an
object property using either a string or
number
t of string is simply the index
signature type
below is the syntax for index signature
if you have a type with number index
signature e of t will just be a number
map types
taking an existing type and making each
of its property optional is a typical
undertaking
because this happens frequently enough
in javascript
typescript has a new feature called map
types that allows you to define new
types based on existing ones
the new types turn each property in the
old type in the same way in a map type
for example make all the properties
optional or the read-only type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to the type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more members
this is the simplest map type and its
parts the syntax is similar to the index
signature with a 4 in the middle there
are three sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
the little union of string the names of
the properties to iterate over a stored
in case
and third one the properties type is a
result
next we have conditional types
based on the condition given as a type
relationship test
a conditional type chooses one of the
two alternative types when t can be
assigned to u the type is x and when it
can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variable a conditional type t
extends u
so x is to y and is either resolved to x
or y or delayed
whether to resolve to x or y or to
differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type system has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
in conditional types we also have
distributive conditional type
that is a conditional type in which the
check type is bait type parameter
during instantiation distributive
conditional types are automatically
distributed over union types
supporting libraries from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files to guarantee that
typescript and javascript support works
well right out of the box
and typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using these declaration
files with typescript
one drawback is since while upgrading
typescript
we must also deal with the changes of
typescript built-in declaration files
which can be difficult when the dom api
is changed so regularly
and the other
drawback is that customizing these files
to meet your needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
so to overcome this a new feature like
types
was added that allow us to override a
specific built-in library
then we can update typescript and lock
the file in dependency management
ensuring that it utilizes the same
version of dom types as a result we can
update the types on our own schedule
then with
then with typescript 4.5
we can update typescript and log file in
our dependency management
await type and promise improvements
the weighted type is the new utility
introduced in typescript
this type is intended to represent
activities such as await in async
functions and the then method on
promises
notably the way they recursively unwrap
promises
existing apis such as javascript
built-in like promise.all
promise.race and others can benefit from
awaited time
in fact some of promise.all inference
concerns provided as foundation for
awaited promise.all combine certain
traits with awaited to produce far
superior inference results
tail recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies potential
infinite recursion or any type expansion
that take a long time and damage your
editor experience
it often leak fails
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while deconstructing an
indefinitely deep type or working with
types that provide a lot of intermediate
results
let's jump into visual studio code and
look at an example
the trim left type for example removes
spaces from the beginning of string like
time when provided a string type with
space at the beginning trim left returns
the reminder of the string to the user
this type is handy but it will throw an
error if a string contains more than 50
leading spaces
this is problematic because these types
are frequently used in modeling
operations on strings
such as parsers for url routers
to make matters worse a more powerful
type useful generates more type
installations resulting in even
additional input length restrictions
trim left is written in such a way that
it is tail recursive on one branch when
it calls itself again it returns a
result instantly and does nothing with
it
because these tabs don't require any
intermediate outcomes they can be
constructed more rapidly and without
activating many of typescript built-in
type recursion heuristics
next we have assert signatures
the set signature features allow us to
construct functions that operate as type
cards as a side effect
instead of returning their boolean
result explicitly
consider a below example
after a search ring typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input
to prevent this most people just make
the parameter input string which is fine
but it also moves the type checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
this option is beneficial
if this function ever returns typescript
can filter the type of input to string
exactly like it would be if it were
inside an if block with a type card
to make this safe the asset function
must either give an error or not return
at all if the asset
assession isn't true
and lastly we have recursive type
aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has been limited
the reason for which
is because each type aliases must be
capable of substituting itself for
whatever it aliases
because this isn't always possible the
compiler rejects some recursive aliases
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot that involves combining
the two creating a type alias and
extracting the type's recursive
operations into interfaces
interfaces can be recursive but their
expressiveness is limited and type
aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type alias and extracting the types
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
by establishing an interface users may
write what was practically the same code
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and other object types
because they introduce a level of
indirection
and their whole structure does not need
to be eagerly built up
however many found the workaround of
introducing the interface to be
inconvenient
and there was nothing wrong with the old
version of value or array that used
array directly in concept
this is the chat application where we
have two users
and from the user one will send the
message hello
and the user 2 will receive it and from
the user 2 will send the message hi
and the user 1 receives it so this is
basically a simple chat application how
we can create
how are you
so this is basically a simple chat
application which we can create
so in this video we will learn to make
this chat application from the scratch
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn watch
the video till the end so that you don't
miss out anything so without wasting any
further time let's get started first of
all we will create a new folder
so i'll go to my d drive and i'll create
a new folder
i'll name the folder as
chat
tab so after creating this new folder
so we will go to visual studio code open
a new window in new window we will open
the folder which we created
we created the folder in d drive
we will first create the user interface
to create the user interface for that we
need to create a new file called
index.html
so i've successfully created the new
file index.html
so we'll change the title
we'll name the title as io chat
next after this will open the link
before this we should know what is cdn
a cdn is a network of servers that
distributes content from an origin
server throughout the world by catching
content close to where each end user is
accessing the internet via a web enabled
device
the content they request is first stored
on the origin server and is then
replicated and stored elsewhere as
needed
so we will use bootstrap cdn and query
cdn for our project
so we'll use the link tag
the link element allows authors to link
the document to other resources
we'll click on the link
so for this to get the bootstrap cdn
we will
go to the browser and type bootstrap cdn
so we'll copy this link
for bootstrap cdn
and we'll paste it here
bootstrap is the most popular css
framework for developing responsive and
mobile first websites
bootstrap 5 is the newest version of
bootstrap
and bootstrap is free open source css
framework directed at responsive mobile
first front-end web development
it contains css and javascript based on
design templates for forms buttons
navigation and other interface
components
after this next we need jquery cdn
next we will
next we'll get the jquery cdn and write
it in the script tags
so i'll select script
the script element allows authors to
include dynamic script and data blocks
in their documents
the element does not represent content
for the user
to get the cdn
for jquery
go to the browser
and just type
jquery cdn
and open the first link
click on uncompressed
and
copy this
go back to the visual studio code
and
paste it
so after this is done
jquery is fast small and feature with
javascript library it makes things like
html document transversal and
manipulation event handling animation
and ajax much simpler with an easy to
use api
that works across a multitude of browser
with the combination of versatility and
extensibility
so after this we'll take one more script
tag and this time we will include
the
we'll take one more script tag inside
this script tag we will enter the client
site socket dot io web api that will
work inside the browser you can go to
the browser and search socket dot io you
will get all the information related to
socket dot io
so just go and type
socket.io
here
just go to the browser and type
socket.io and on this website socket.io
you have all the documentation and all
the details to get started with
socket.io so you can go through the
socket.io here
so in the script tags
i'll write source
and just type socket
socket dot io dot js
so after this
we'll create a new div tag
so the div element has no special
meaning at all it represents its
children it can be used with the class
language and title attributes to markup
semantics common to a group of
consecutive elements
so inside this div will create a new
class
new class container
so class is basically a space separated
list of classes of the element classes
allow css and javascript to select and
access specific elements via the class
selector or functions like the method
document get elements by class name
so after this
we will create another div
class
rule
inside this will create one more diff
class
this scholar medium for this class is
used when the device size is medium or
greater than 768 pixel and the maximum
width of the container is 720 pixel and
you want the width equal to 4 columns
that is when we use this function column
medium 4.
next we'll create another div
class
well
so after this will provide the heading
h3
the h3 element represents a section
heading
so in this will provide the heading as
online users
you can change the headings whatever you
want to but i'll keep it as online users
so after this we'll create an unordered
list
in this class
list group
and id
so after this we'll create a one more
div
in this div class
we'll provide column medium
of size 8
this column medium 8 starts for large
column
then we'll create a div another div
class chat
where id
is equal to chat
then i'll create a form
the this form element represents a
collection of form associated elements
some of which can represent editable
values that can be submitted into a
server or processing
perform id
is equal to
for message form
this will create a diff class
thumb group
next we'll create a label
so label element represents a caption in
a user interface the caption can be
associated with specific form control
known as label elements label controlled
either using for attribute or by putting
the form control inside the label
element itself
so use the label element inside that
will write enter message
next we'll create a text area
use the label text area
so inside text area we'll create a class
form control
and
id
message
so text area element represents a
multi-line plain text edit control for
the elements raw value the contents of
the control represent the controls
default value
after the text area
will
just
write
then we will create an input element
input element of
will
assign a type submit
class
button
value
send message
in double quotes
so this input basically it represents a
type data field usually with the form
control to allow the user to edit the
data
so we have finished with the user
interface we'll just save this
and run it in the browser right click
and open with live server
so here we go
we have created the html
but
we we will now create assign few css
elements
we just need the margin top
for the body so we'll assign that
so we'll create styles element
the style element allows authors to
embed style information in their
documents the style element is one of
the several inputs to the styling
processing model the element does not
represent content for the user
so in the style
we'll just write this body
and will assign margin top
30 pixel
save this and we'll go to the browser
and just refresh
so till now we have created the user
interface
we will just go to the browser and run
this user interface
just right click and click on open with
live server
now we will create a new file called
server.js
and will go to the terminal
in terminal we will run two commands
first of all we need to install
socket.typo for that we'll run npm
and there is one prerequisite we need to
have node.js installed in our device
so then run the command node package
manager npm
install
socket.typo
socket.io is a library that enables
real-time bi-directional and even-based
communication between the browser and
the server
it consists of a node.js server and a
javascript client library for the
browser
after installing socket.io then we need
to install express
for that run the command npm install
express
express is a minimal and flexible
node.js web application framework that
provides a robust set of features for
web and mobile applications
after installing
socket.typeonexpress you will get these
two files
packet.json file
and package
log.json
next go to the server.js
wherein i will paste few lines of code
in the line 1 creates an express
application the express function is a
top level function exported by the
express module
then we have const listen
and then we require and socket dot io
then we we have created a variable app
express method then we have created a
variable server
so this server
that is we use the module http
so it creates a module http to use the
http server and client we must require
http the http interfaces in node.js are
designed to support many features of the
protocol which have been traditionally
difficult to use in particular large
possible chunk encoded messages the
interface is careful to never buffer
entire request or responses so the user
is able to stream data
then we have another variable io where
we require socket.typo server
and similarly we are listening in the
port 3000
so in port 3000 it starts a server
listening for connection
a net dot server can be an tcp or an ipc
server depending on what it listens to
do
then we have app.get
here the request is declared but its
value is never read we have request and
response
then we are routing it on the local host
3000
so in this line we are transferring the
file at the given path so automatically
sets the content type response header
field the callback is invoked when the
transfer is complete or when an error
occurs
be sure to check request response sent
if you wish to attempt responding as the
header and some data may be already been
transferred
here we are connecting the client to the
server and here we add plug details to
the customer array and here we are
checking the current connections
and then we disconnect from the server
using the disconnect function
next we delete the plug details and
the again we show the current
connections
here for on the socket.on we send
messages function data and then we
console.log the data then we emit the
new messages
so then we have written console.log
server is listening
so now we will run this code and check
if the server is listening
now we will check if the server is
listening for that will run the command
node
server
and here we go server is listening
will just go and
run the local host 3000 on the browser
go to the
new tab and just run localhost 3000
and here we go
it's running and when we come back to
the code
we can see it shows one socket connected
so again if we go and open it in a new
browser
and just run the local host
and go back to the code it will show two
sockets connected
so we are almost done we just have a
small part left out we'll go to
index.html
and here
we'll just scroll down
and above body we'll just paste few
lines of code
so here basically we are just creating a
function to get data form
so we'll get message form
and we'll we are creating variables
message and we are creating variables
chat
so basically in this line we will know
form between click event handle
and
then we will prevent default from
submission
next in this line we will trap data for
text box and call server
then we'll create clear
then we will clear the form text box
then we'll console.log submitted
so our program is finished
now we'll just run and check the code
so we'll save this code
go to the browser
refresh it
so i have the two browsers i have opened
it in two separate window we'll just
check if the application is working so
we'll send the message hi
and here we go we have received the
message so we can say hello
so the chat application is working
successfully
we'll first look at beginner level
interview questions
what is typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of javascript
typescript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft the limitations
of javascript for developing large-scale
applications at microsoft and among its
external customers led to the creation
of typescript
because of the difficulty of working
with complicated javascript code there
was a demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in the
browser or nodejs or any other
application
typescript is javascript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
javascript typescript is a scripting
language that understands javascript and
uses type inference to provide powerful
capabilities without additional code
explain the features of typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly typed superset
of javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodejs comprehend
javascript typescript compiles
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript
typescript unlike its competitors does
not require a dedicated virtual machine
or a specific runtime environment to run
typescript is superset of javascript it
is strongly syntactical that superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing typescript is a
large-scale application development
language that transcompiles to
javascript existing javascript programs
are also valid typescript programs
because typescript is a superset of
javascript
typescript is static
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can pass null optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
you can declare some arguments in the
function optional by utilizing optional
parameter features so that the client is
not necessary to supply a value to
optional parameters
object oriented language when it comes
to object oriented programming with
javascript typescript shines
because of the class keyword it makes
object oriented programming look quite
similar to programming in other object
oriented languages like c sharp or java
what are export and import keywords in
typescript
import keyword is used to export
declaration example export star from
module
and the export keyword is used to export
any variable function and type aliases
below is the example for import keyword
and export keyword
can typescript be used for the backend
typescript can be generally used for
backend applications by using node.js
and having additional safety that the
language brings
how to declare a variable in typescript
let and const are the two methods to
declare variables variable names can
contain alphabets and numeric digits
they cannot contain spaces and special
characters except the underscore and the
dollar sign variable names cannot begin
with the digital flow is the example
code where we have declared a variable
with let method and we have declared a
variable inside a function
list the applications of typescript
script can be used to develop javascript
applications for both client-side and
server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code typescript is used for building
large-scale applications for enterprises
how can a base constructor be called
from a child class
a base class constructor can be called
from child class using the super method
as shown in the example
what are getters and setters
getters and setters intercept access to
a member of the object
they give us a way of having finer grain
control over how a member access each
objects a getter method starts with the
keyword get
and the setter method starts with the
keyword set
what is the purpose of
tsconfig.json file
tsconfig.json file is a json format file
in which we can specify different
options to tell the compiler how to
compile a given project this file in the
directory indicates that the directory
is the typescript project root
list the advantages of typescript
typescript highlights errors at the
compilation time during the time of
development
any browser or javascript engine can run
typescript
it has a namespace concept by defining a
module typescript supports strongly
typed or static typing typescript has
the advantages of being tightly typed or
allowing static typing
it may confirm type correctness at the
compile time because of static typing
what are rest parameters in typescript
when the number of parameters that a
function will receive is not known or
can vary we can use rest parameters
we can pass zero or more arguments to
the rest parameters the compiler will
create an array of arguments with the
rest parameter name
how to compile typescript with visual
studio code
visual studio code includes typescript
language support but does not include
the typescript compiler we need to
install the typescript compiler either
globally or in your workspace to
transpile typescript source code to
javascript the easiest way to install
typescript is through node package
manager
the node.js package manager if you have
npm installed you can install typescript
globally on your computer by using this
command npm install hyphen g type script
we can test the installed typescript by
checking the version or help for this
run the command tsc
hyphen hyphen version
list access modifier supported by
typescript typescript supports three
access modifiers
protected
private
and public in protected all class
members can access them but the instance
cannot but in private it's only
accessible by members whereas in public
it is accessible by members child
classes and instance of the class
list the disadvantages of typescript the
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code typescript does not support
abstract classes
an extra compilation step for converting
typescript into javascript typescript
has overly complicated typing system
how to debug a typescript file
to debug a typescript file a dot js
source map file is needed to debug the
file
compile the dot ts file with the source
map flag for generating source map file
use the command
type script tsc space hyphen source map
file.ts source mapping url is equal to
file.js.map
how can we convert a string to a number
with typescript in typescript conversion
from a string to a number can be done
using the following commands parse int
method
and we have parse float method
and number method
explain type aliases
type aliases give a type a new name type
aliases are similar to interfaces in
that they can be used to name primitives
unions tuples and any other kinds that
you would have to define by hand
otherwise
alyasing doesn't truly create a new type
instead it gives that type a new name
aliasing a primitive isn't very useful
however it can be used for documentation
purposes type aliases like interfaces
can be in general
all we have to do is add type parameters
and utilize them on the right side of
alias declaration below is the syntax
for type aliases
what are nullible types in
typescript null and undefined are the
two special types in typescript that
have the values null and undefined
respectively they are not particularly
useful much like void
null and undefined are subclasses of all
other types by default
that means you can give things like
number null and undefined values
when the strict null checks flag is said
however null and undefined can only be
assigned to unknown
any and their respective types the one
exception being that undefined is also
assignable to want this helps to avoid a
lot of frequent errors you can use the
union type string null undefined if you
want to send in either a string null or
undefined
what is in operator in typescript
the in operator serves as a type
narrowing expression
the true branch narrows to types that
have been an optional or required
property n and the false branch narrows
to the types that have an optional or
missing properties in for a n in x
expression as shown in the example below
where n is a string literal or string
literal type
and x is a union type explain index
types in typescript
using index types we can get the
compiler to check code that utilizes the
dynamic property names a typical
javascript pattern for example is to
select a subset of an object properties
we may build and use this function in
typescript using the index type query
and indexed access operators
in this example key of t the index type
query operator for any type t key of t
is the union of known public property
names of t and t of k the indexed access
operator is the second operator the type
syntax reflects the expression syntax in
this case t of k can be like index type
queries be used in generic environment
which is where it's truly potentially
seen all you have to do now is make sure
that the type variable k
extends to k of t
what are map types
typescript has a feature called map
types that allow you to define new types
based on the existing ones
the new type turns each property into
the old type in the same way in a map
type
it's important to note that this syntax
refers to a type rather than a member
you can use an intersection type to add
more numbers as you can see in the
example it is the simplest map type and
its parts are type keys and type flags
where syntax is similar to the index
signatures
with four in the middle there are three
sections in total
the type variable k is assigned to each
property one by one
and the literal union of strings the
name of properties to iterate over the
stored in case
and properties type as a result
what is meant by contextual typing
when there is a type on one side of the
equation but not on the other the
typescript compiler finds out the form
we can omit typing on the right side as
typescript can work it out automatically
this increases the amount of work needed
to type code
distinguish between typescript and
javascript typescript is an object
oriented programming language whereas
javascript is a scripting language
typescript supports static typing
javascript does not support static
typing
in typescript error can be found and
corrected during a compile time in
javascript errors can be found only
during runtime as it is an interpreted
language
there is support for
es3 es4 5 and 6 in typescript
whereas in javascript no support for
compiling
in typescript functions can have
optional parameters whereas in
javascript this is not possible
in typescript converted into javascript
code
to be understandable for browsers
javascript can be directly used in
browsers
typescript has proper build setup don't
package manager is required for static
type definitions no build setup is
required in javascript
what is jsx
jsx is an xml like syntax that can be
embed it is intended to be turned into
legitimate javascript though the
semantics of that transformation will
vary depending on the implementation
typescript allows you to embed jsx type
verify it and compile it to javascript
immediately jsx needs to be translated
into a valid typescript we use the jsx
file with the dot dsx extension
define static typing
static typing refers to a compiler
having variables parameters and object
members that are recognizable at the
compilation type this helps in detecting
early errors static typing as is an
important concept
static typing is when the compiler
enforces that the values use the same
type here's an example
what is meant by type inference
when you don't specify an explicit type
for variable typescript can infer it
type inference is the term for this this
is normally done during the declaration
when the variables or parameters are
initialized
typescript recognizes that the variable
foo is a string even if we don't mention
string as a type
here is an example
how to create objects in typescript
objects are collection of keys and
values that resemble a dictionary
the keys must be one of a kind resemble
arrays and are sometimes referred to as
associate arrays
an object type in typescript refers to
any value with properties it can be
defined simply by specifying the
properties and the kinds of these
properties
as an example
explain different data types in
typescript
number both integer and floating point
numbers are represented by the data type
number
boolean has true and false values
string it is used to denote a string of
characters
void is usually applied to function
return types
null it's used when an object isn't
worth anything
undefined indicates the value assigned
to an uninitialized variable
any any type of value can be assigned to
a variable if declared with any data
type
what are the benefits of using
typescript
compilation javascript is an interpreted
language thus there is no need to
compile it as a result it must be run to
ensure authenticity if there is an error
you write all the code only to find no
output as a result you will have to
spend hours looking for false in the
code
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler
if typescript detects any syntax
mistakes it will compile the code and
generate compilation error
this aids in detecting errors before the
execution of the script
the next benefit is it provides an
optional type system for javascript code
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can pass null
optional arguments are a feature of
typescript
you can declare some optional arguments
in the function by utilizing optional
parameter features so the decline does
not need to supply a value to optional
parameters
strong static typing
javascript does not have a powerful
static typing system
through the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls can deduce the
type of variable defined with node type
based on its value
typescript supports object-oriented
programming typescript support classes
interfaces inheritance and other
object-oriented programming principles
typescript supports type definition
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions
external javascript libraries are
defined in typescript definition files
as a result it can include these
libraries in typescript code
how to install typescript
typescript is a javascript programming
language for use in application
typescript extends javascript with
optional types that support tools for
large-scale javascript application in
any browser or any host on any other
operating system to install typescript
globally with node package manager which
means you can run the typescript command
from anywhere in your terminal to
install the latest stable version of
typescript you just need to run the
command npm install hyphen g space type
script this will install the latest
version of typescript
what are decorators
a decorator is a type of declaration
that can be used to decorate the class
declaration method accessor property or
argument
decorators take the form
expression where expression must
evaluate to a function
that will be called with information
about the decorated declaration when it
is called at runtime
what are mixins
combining simpler particle classes is a
popular approach of constructing classes
from reusable components
for languages like scala you may be
familiar with the concept of mixins or
characteristics
to extend a base class the design relies
on generics and class inheritance the
finest mix in support
in typescript is provided through the
class expression pattern
explain classes in typescript
classes are not supported in javascript
es5 or earlier this feature that
typescript inherits from es6
a class is a collection of items with
similar characteristics fields methods
constructor blocks
nested classes and interfaces are all
included in the classes
below is the syntax to declare a class
in terms of oops a class is a template
for producing objects
what is the namespace and how to declare
it
the namespace is used to group
functionalities logically to enable a
single or group of link functionalities
the namespace can include interfaces
classes functions and variables
the namespace keyword followed by the
namespace name can be used to construct
the namespace curly brackets can be used
to define all interfaces classes and
other objects
below is the syntax for namespace
explain the components of typescript
internally the typescript language is
separated into three layers each of this
layer is further subdivided into
language compiler
and language services
language it is written in typescript and
includes typescript language components
it includes syntax keywords and type
annotations
compiler the typescript compiler
converts typescript programs into
javascript code it also converts our
typescript code to javascript code
parsing and type checking it
it provides information that allows
editors and other tools to deliver
greater assistance capabilities like
automated refactoring and intelligence
it adds a layer of abstraction to the
core compiler pipeline
what are the recent advancements in
typescript
typescript 4.2 has been released and it
includes more flexible type annotations
tougher checks and additional
configuration choices and a few breaking
changes
rest arguments can now be placed
anywhere in triple type in type error
messages type aliases are no longer
enlarged resulting in a better developer
experience
typescript 4.2 brings the language one
step closer to its aim of accurately
typing javascript at any size anywhere
javascript is used
describe as syntax in typescript
the as is an additional syntax in
typescript for type assertion it was
introduced as the original syntax
conflicted with jsx
while using jsx with typescript only as
styled assertions can be used
define lambda function
typescript provides shorthand syntax for
defining function expressions a lambda
function is an anonymous function
without a name
below is an example for lambda function
what are conditional types in typescript
based on a condition given as a type
relationship test a conditional type
chooses one of the two alternative types
when t can be assigned to you the type
is x and when t can't the type is y
because the condition depends on one or
more type variables a conditional type t
extends to u
x is to y and is either resolved to x or
y or delayed whether to resolve to x or
y or to differ when t or u contains type
variables is determined by whether the
type systems has enough information to
conclude that t is always assignable to
you
what is an interface with reference to
typescript
the interface defines the syntax for
classes to follow a class implementing
an interface implements all its members
it can be reference but not instantiated
typescript compiler uses an interface
for type checking
what is a declare keyword in typescript
as javascript does not have typescript
declaration to use it in the typescript
file without any compilation error
declare keyword is used
the keyword is used for ambient methods
and declarations to define a variable
that exists elsewhere
now we will look at advanced level
interview questions
what are object oriented principles
supported by typescript
all object oriented principles
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
and obstruction are supported by
typescript
encapsulation is a major component of
object oriented programming language and
its method of structuring code so that
each block of code has its own set of
access points for external code
polymorphism occurs when many class
inherit from the same parent and
overwrite the same functionality
each of those kit classes is now
responsible for implementing a property
or method but they may do so it on their
own unique way
inheritance
typescript makes creating an object
model an inheritance chain a breeze to
construct classes
simply use the standard class keyword
abstraction is a method of modeling
objects in a system that separates the
responsibilities of the classes or type
from the code that inherits it
explain index signatures in typescript
index signatures interact with the key
of and t of k
the type of an index signature argument
must be either a string or a number
if your type has a string index
signature key of t will be a string
or a number because in javascript we can
access an object property using either
string or numbers and t of string is
simply the index signatures type
the index signature consists of the
index name and its type in square
bracket
followed by colon and the value type
what are our search signatures
the asset signature features allows us
to construct functions that operate as
type guards as a side effect instead of
returning their boolean result
explicitly
after a search string typescript has no
way of knowing if you have guaranteed
the type of input to prevent this most
people just make the parameter input
string which is fine
but it also moves the type of checking
problem somewhere and in circumstances
where you just want to fail hard having
the option is beneficial
what is type assertion explain its types
a type assertion is similar to a type
cast in other languages but it does not
do any additional data verification or
restructuring it has no effect on
runtime and is only used by the compiler
there are two types of assertions
one is the as syntax other is the angle
bracket syntax
below is the example for async syntax
and angle bracket syntax
explain how typescript files can be
supported from node modules
typescript includes a series of
declaration files however there are two
drawbacks to using this declaration
files with typescript
one is while upgrading typescript we
must deal with changes to typescript's
built-in declaration files
and the other is customizing these files
to meet the needs and the demands of
project dependencies is difficult
a new feature like at the rate types was
added that allows to override the
specific built-in library then we can
update typescript and the log file in
dependency management ensuring that it
utilizes the same version of the dom
types as a result we can update the
types on our own schedule
explain the typescript generics
typescript generics is a tool for
creating reusable components in
typescript it builds a component that
can interact with various data kinds it
enables users to consume these
components while also using their own
kinds
the identity function now has a type
variable called type
this type allows us to capture the type
of data the user supplies for example a
number or a string so that we can use it
later we are going to utilize type as
the return type once more below is the
syntax for typescript generics
what is recursive type aliases
the ability to recursively reference
type aliases has always been eliminated
the reason for this is because each type
aliases must be capable of substituting
itself for whatever it aliases
interfaces can be recursive
but their expressiveness is limited and
type aliases cannot
that involves combining the two creating
a type aliases and extracting the types
recursive portions into interfaces it's
effective
typescript has no trouble working with
the interfaces and the other object
types because they introduce a level of
indirection and their whole structure
does not need to be eagerly built up
explain tale recursion elimination on
conditional types
when typescript identifies infinite
recursion or any type expansions that
take a long time and damage your editor
experience
as a result typescript includes
heuristics to ensure that it doesn't run
off the tracks while working with types
that provide a lot of intermediate
results
the trim left type removes spaces from
the beginning of string like type when
provided a string type with a space at
the beginning trim left returns a
reminder of the string to the user
advance type script removes tail
recursion from conditional types it can
prevent
intermediary instantiations as one
branch of conditional type is merely
another conditional type
explain the awaited type and promise
improvements this type is intended to
represent activities such as await in
async functions and the dot then method
on promises notably the way they
recursively unwrap promises
existing apis such as javascript
built-ins like promise.all promise.trace
and others can benefit from the updated
type in fact some of promise dot all's
inference concerns provided as
foundation for awaited promise dot all
combine certain traits with the awaited
to produce far superior inference
results
so with that we have reached the end of
this video thank you so much for being
here keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you